welcome the fat man our Batman I'm Kevin
Smith
okay man they just had the tcas going on
right now out here in California the
Television Critics Association and
that's where like every network rolls
out the stuff that they're doing and and
the stars of the programs they already
have on the air I did it once years ago
for the clerks cartoon I don't know if
we ever did it for AMC for comic book
men I don't think so but I know I did it
for the clerk's cartoon and you sit
there and talk to critics ask questions
usually it's for shows that are
returning more so than new shows but
they just announced today at CW's
presentation at the TCA that a certain
hockey jersey wearing baseball cap
subverting large man is going to be
directing an episode of Supergirl and
that person is me proving once again
that if you just tell people in life
what you want it'll happen
I've literally just mentioned that loud
a few weeks months ago at this point I
was like I would love to direct an
episode of Supergirl and guess what
happened now I'm directing an episode of
Supergirl thrilling I'm gonna do that
for everything now watch this [ __ ]
I would love to directing an episode of
Game of Thrones [ __ ] well you know what
takes time took time of Supergirl
amazing job for me because I love the
show but watching the show now i binge
Dahl weekend I've seen a lot of episodes
that particularly well they did a
crossover with flash and that's where I
kind I saw the pilot and the flight
flour crossover flash and I watched
episode seven that was the birth of Jon
Jones Jon Jones he was revealed as the
Martian Manhunter spoilers a lot of
spoilers in this yet I [ __ ] love this
show it found its footing in Episode
seven that's where the show absolutely
takes off man a incredible cast across
the boards just like in flash including
Melissa on me because I want to say
Benoit but you probably don't say that
it's probably been noise but Benoit
sound sexy Melissa Benoist I think as I
say been a waste I'm not sure but [ __ ]
she's dynamite she she gave a
performance and I'm not just sucking
dick as I'm heading up there like I
[ __ ] even if I don't get the job I'd
be saying this [ __ ] there's an episode
where they do Kara Supergirl finds red K
red kryptonite Maxwell Lord Maxwell
[ __ ] Lord is in it man as their Lex
Luthor [ __ ] are so smart who make
this show I love it so much
he puts the increase in red K he doesn't
know his red K he's trying to create
kryptonite but it winds up being red K
and it's she gets a whiff of it and it
changes her demeanor so she becomes bad
Supergirl so it's on CBS originally the
whole first season this summer this this
but now right now in the summer they're
running reruns and this season in the
fall it goes to CW where it belongs the
d CW [ __ ] because that's where
you got arrow flash legends of tomorrow
and now Supergirl all together in one
universe and stuff so they do this
episode where you know it's on CBS ain't
gonna get [ __ ] crazy dark certainly
not gonna get as dark as that Batman V
Superman movie or Suicide Squad so you
know she's not killing people like of
course if a god you know suddenly it was
just like rogue they'd be snapping necks
she does do a badass [ __ ] thing we
should pitch his Cat grin off her
[ __ ] balcony man lets her drop like
50 stories then catches her the last
minute and she's like that's what power
is I was [ __ ] dope but the best
moment of this episode which is again
like you know Kara's gone bad like you
know it's a comic book pretense and [ __ ]
but once red K's on the table you're
like this could be goofy as [ __ ] and
they turned in the most touching [ __ ]
episode of the series man they have a
little homage to Superman 3 remember
Superman 3 Chris Reeves when he's drunk
Superman the bars pitching peanuts and
busting bottles they actually had her do
it in this episode that was sweet for
old-timer like myself but when she comes
out of the red K influence man she has a
conversation with her sister Kara and
her sister Alex at the heart of the
[ __ ] show like two stepsisters
beautiful relationship one of the best
sister relationships you've ever seen in
[ __ ] TV show in your life they're
doing a Supergirl right now sure Melissa
gives this incredible [ __ ]
heartbreaking performance like true like
pulling off like true violation because
she you know went rogue she went mean
she's like every mean thought I ever had
came out and that sounds corny me Santa
cuz I'm a middle-aged man is [ __ ] but
she [ __ ] oh my god she 800% just aced
it man pitch perfect [ __ ] performance
I was rolling tears this is one of those
shows that makes you cry believe me I
cried so hard in the episode where that
Manhunter it's called man the episode
where you dude the background of Jon
Jones and they also did back
of Kara and Alex when they were kids and
like I'm a sucker for any time a [ __ ]
hears a scream and tries to go save
somebody and they did that like in this
[ __ ] episode they show Kara is a
young kid like on the beach like just
little touches like this she's like
looking up at the sky at the birds and
people on the beach are talking to Alex
her older sister like your [ __ ]
sister's weird man and she goes over her
sisters and she's not really a sister
she's you know Kara Kara zor-el from the
planet Krypton who was sent here y'all
know what the [ __ ] shows about I have
to explain see so anyway she's looking
up at the [ __ ] birds and her sisters
like don't [ __ ] him what are you doing
man they don't curse on the show but
what are you doing he look making
everyone weirded out and it was a simple
line but I [ __ ] loved it she's like
we don't have birds where I come from
and so she's just staring up at [ __ ]
Birds little touches like that make you
go like [ __ ] somebody gives a [ __ ]
somebody writing these lines man making
touching little moments so in that
middle of the fight with her sister she
hears like a car accident [ __ ] and
[ __ ] smokes over and just like saves
a lady and her kid and [ __ ] hands
like baby to the lady and and the one
beat that was missing was the lady
should have been like you're [ __ ] 12
like and somebody says it later on
they're like a lot of people looking on
couldn't understand how a little girl
did what you did and they tell her
suppress her powers and [ __ ] like that
so it's that was in her childhood that
that's in that same Manhunter episode
they do Jon Jones is Baxter and they do
her backstory as well a little bit this
is heartbreaking [ __ ] comes from the
folks the Berlanti verse of course so
they know what the [ __ ] they're doing
Andrew Kreisberg who is like one of my
favorite [ __ ] people on the planet is
involved in this shows well and you
could tell man he's flash if I'd the
[ __ ] out of this [ __ ] like it is
gripping like the shows gripping it's
funny it's got the three H's that they
always tell you about where I always
tell you about in the writers room over
at those CW shows heart humour heroics
man fires on all cylinders up till
episode 6 nothing wrong with it and
stuff like that but it always felt like
because it was on CBS there's something
they weren't able to do as well as they
do on CW and so by the time they hit
episode 7 it felt like like I was
telling my friend like remember you
probably don't remember this Butch
Cassidy and the Sundance Kid at one
point they're going for a job to like
guard the [ __ ] very railroads that
they're constantly trying to rob and
[ __ ] and so there's old-timers telling
like gotta shoot that can over there in
the distance puts a gun in Sundance and
goes fire and he keeps trying to hit
he can't because he's just doing it like
this without [ __ ] moving and so the
old man is just like I knew it and he
walked away and then Sundance is like
can I move and he said what he's like
can I move and he goes yeah and he pulls
out bam bam bam takes all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of the way felt like by Episode
seven somebody let these [ __ ]
move because it was soaring you know no
pun intended because it is about
Supergirl but my god it's [ __ ]
fantastic stuff 46 year old man should
not be [ __ ] on and on over the show
but I can't help it man once again just
like flash they [ __ ] go to the DC toy
box and pull out every [ __ ] character
man they don't give a [ __ ] they don't
belong to Supergirl they're like we're
allowed to play in the Superman Universe
so we're gonna give her all Superman's
[ __ ] villains man they do toy man and
his Henry charity playing [ __ ] toy
man you know but every tyranny was in
the boys of st. Vincent one of the like
greatest [ __ ] TV movies ever made
came out of Canada bout molestation
priests molesting kids not like you know
popcorn is just well done when I say one
of the greatest [ __ ] but that guy that
they got him to play [ __ ] Winslow
Schott the goddamn Toyman and they made
him [ __ ] creepy and [ __ ] it's
astounding the pulling huge talent like
they do on those CW shows they're smart
they brought in Calista Flockhart she's
[ __ ] fantastic plays cat Grinch kind
of like the constant conscience of the
show Cara's best even though she's an
employer and stuff but it's a really
sweet relationship like the first time
he watched an episode the pilot I was
like alright I get it I understand what
they're doing with this character but
know like the deeper you get into the
show man the more they were able to kind
of like do what they do so well over the
CW and now that this show is leaving CBS
and going straight to CW think of what
they're gonna be able to achieve the
first season of [ __ ] Supergirl was
trailing [ __ ] I don't know how
to say I know some people like dude i
watch a show about a girl you're [ __ ]
stupid
I don't know else to say if you like
this [ __ ] you love the flash I mean I
don't want to be reductive but like the
way Supergirl is presented it's almost
like just the female version of the
flash got her own [ __ ] team her own
world her own mission they start the
[ __ ] shows the same where she's like
my planet blew up I'm Kara zor-el and
but I am Supergirl like just that little
thing that would appear at the top of a
comic book when I was kid to give you
the background of all these characters
so I love this [ __ ] man it became my
[ __ ] religion and you know look I'm
I'm happy to see any show that like puts
a positive spin or a female spin on the
big boys club we all know that
superheroes and stuff that's not true
51% of the population is women a lot of
mother I go to Connor all the time it
ain't a sausage party
it's [ __ ] women out there girls that
love this [ __ ] but you know you got to
preach it to them you gotta give it to
him in a young age and stuff and with
this show you got a whole generation of
girls growing up thinking about Superman
about about Supergirl the way I thought
about Superman when I was a kid me can't
can't [ __ ] be it unless you can see
it as they say and [ __ ] and that show
shows you [ __ ] like look there's your
hero and it's not just her because
they're powers like the rest of the cast
around her including like you know her
mom and cat grant and her sister like
Alex so Soufan so wonderful such a sweet
goddamn show that's a spurt of to say
the least most of those CW shows are but
as a fan of DC Comics they did [ __ ]
silver banshee they did live wire she
came from [ __ ] cartoon versus
Superman animated series they've done
Brainiac indigo but Brainiac 8 I thought
it's [ __ ] crazy dude we're living a
world where they didn't do just Brainiac
but they did indigo the girl Brainiac
and it was the girl that played the
woman that played Supergirl back on
Smallville Laura Vandenberg so if you're
like a fan of deep cuts they do that in
the Berlin severs next season Lynda
Carter gonna play the president United
States on Supergirl Wonder Woman like
[ __ ] how cool is that
who else but David Harewood has figured
as his name Harewood as the [ __ ]
Martian Manhunter like I remember
reading an interview with people that
were working on DC Comics movies on who
was but they were like we're not ever
gonna use the [ __ ] Martian Manhunter
because how do you play that character
so stupid it's just big green guy from
Mars you know as reductive thinking they
found a way to [ __ ] make him almost
the equal star footing on the show -
Supergirl you give a [ __ ] about his
journey man hank henshaw who really
isn't hanging henshaw he's really Jon
Jones from the from the planet Mars they
showed the [ __ ] Martian war dude
there's an episode with a [ __ ] white
Martian I'm gonna cry talking about cuz
I was sitting that on my desk watching
it the more I'm awakened Baker and I was
sitting there [ __ ] watching and I was
like no no no [ __ ] and it was a white
Martian man like that's straight out the
comics too and it was like he was like
the white Martian just came up from the
center of the earth and killed my people
they burn them all and [ __ ] just like in
the [ __ ] comics he lost his kids and
his family it's touching [ __ ] I saw
somebody online go
yeah but the origin age straight from
the comics eat a [ __ ] dick
are you nuts like [ __ ] somebody gives
you something this good if you're picky
you and be like yeah but that exists
exactly how John good Jones come to
earth and don't eat a dick if you like
eating a dick eat the other thing
whatever the opposite is eat the thing
you don't want to eat how dare you say
that they're doing the Lord's work with
these [ __ ] shows man it's just like
when a new writer comes on like I didn't
create daredevil one day I did write
daredevil and I'm sure I wrote a story
that some people like that ain't my
[ __ ] daredevil and stuff so you might
have that reaction going that ain't my
Martian Manhunter I think you should
give it a chance man I [ __ ] went
through that whole [ __ ] thing this
weekend just like a [ __ ] junkie i
binge like crazy insanely insanely good
man I love the show and so I look
forward to going up there and [ __ ]
shooting it here nobody knows this and
it might change and stuff and I might
lose the job by talking about this but
[ __ ] it and maybe they've been announced
at the TSTC I don't know we did this
before they announced that the TCA and
had it ready to go online but Andrew
Kreisberg told me that the name of the
episode is super girl lives I'm gonna
cry talking about this name of the
script that I wrote back in 1996 was
called Superman lives that's what they
do over that [ __ ] Berlanti verse they
make magic they reach into your [ __ ]
heart they leave it in Twain they full
it fill it full of [ __ ] stuffing and
[ __ ] marshmallows and so if added up
they show it to you first like [ __ ]
and then put it back in your chest and
sew you back up and you're happy for it
man they know how to [ __ ] decide the
ticker I love this [ __ ] show can't
wait to work on it man I'm so happy to
be able to talk about it sitting on this
information for awhile and that's tough
for me you know that I like to [ __ ]
blab and [ __ ] now I can the c-w folks
like you can't say [ __ ] into the tcas
and I was like will it affect me getting
the job they're like yes as a guy saying
[ __ ] because I want to go up to
Vancouver that's where they shoot the
show now last season they were all in
Los Angeles they shoot it now up in the
same place where they shoot all the
Berlanti shows I can't wait to go up
there man take a visit to - Supergirl
weld National City and and and and try
to play I might get to play with
Superman they've added Superman this
year
you know [ __ ] mind-bending this is
for me I was never gonna direct that
Superman movie but I did write it back
in the day to be able to like work on
so words like good direct Superman like
come on man I owe Andrew Kreisberg the
sloppiest [ __ ] [ __ ] ever committed
to a dick in history and hopefully we'll
roll on that you watch it right here on
fat man on Batman we'll use it to
promote my Supergirl airing I'm sure
it's a coup w will be very happy about I
am very happy about happy to talk about
it with you man there's some breaking
news for you right there Kevin Smith
gonna ruin Supergirl no I've sent him to
try not to men like trust me I went to
flash and I [ __ ] hit it hard and
stuff so I'm looking to do the same
thing if done my homework I'm ready to
bring the heart and stuff they got a lot
more special effects on the show and a
little worried about that man I don't
know how to make people fly I'm sure
someone will teach me how to do that
green screen or some [ __ ] like that or
ropes whatever the [ __ ] they get removed
but yeah man I'm gonna do I'm gonna do
an episode Supergirl that's all the
information I have for you this week so
there's the news that's it
[ __ ] I'm directing Supergirl man I'm
gonna try try every comic book show
there is and then I'm gonna go back in
time and try to direct the ones that I
grew up watching like Batman 66 once we
perfect time travel I will direct a
young Adam West I promise you this
hey this Sunday on AMC man my show with
Greg Grunberg geeking out remember we
did the episode aired after Comic Con
well we're back for our regular run
starts at 11 o'clock on Sunday on AMC
right after the big big fat-ass Walking
Dead special where they're gonna
literally reveal who negan kills I'm
kidding that's never gonna happen not in
the preview you got to wait to see that
stuff but watch the big preview for The
Walking Dead and right after you're
gonna see The Walking Dead themselves me
and Greg Grunberg sitting around talking
about [ __ ] all the things we love I'm
geeking out we speak to Nathan Fillion
we speak to alan tudyk and we speak to a
young up-and-coming filmmaker who's
making a buzz around town in the
independent film world name of JJ Abrams
yes that's right I buried the lead JJ
Abrams is on our [ __ ] first episode
boom drop the mic Greg got him I tried
to call him he was like Kevin who but he
knows Greg so boom we got a show I'm on
the geek announced that's kind of a
preview look same wearing that so anyway
tune in Sunday night man geeking out on
AMC it is a [ __ ] excellent show here
here's how I like this here's how I know
I like the show that I'm on we should
like go figure
if I wasn't on this show and this show
existed without me I'd be so [ __ ]
angry I try to get on the show I would
try to be a correspond
like are you kidding me that's all I do
is talk about the my betters and the
work that they do and that's what we do
every week I'm geeking out kind of like
what we do on Fatman I'm Batman that's
it for Batman Batman I'm Kevin Smith
tune in next time same fad time same fat
channel SModcast calm or YouTube / Gibbs
hey man it's me Kevin Smith thanks for
watching do me a favor click that thing
below that says subscribe every time you
click that you save a baby kitten from
murder